prepare to get emotional as we show you
the saddest of disease deleted scenes
you won't believe how different one of
the studio's most loved characters could
have been he was so mean that Disney
almost canceled the entire movie keep
watching to find out all the deeds
Zootopia
tame collar party there was a whole
concept that got cut from Zootopia
because it was just too upsetting to
watch and that was the idea of a tame
collar the collar was designed to
control predators by giving an electric
shock when they get too excited or too
upset one of the scenes that used the
tame collar is totally heartbreaking to
watch Nick and Judy stumble upon a
teaming party little Morris the bear is
initially excited about his father
Koslow presenting him with a collar at
his special party all of the other
little bears cheer when the collar is
fitted but Kozlov looks on sadly Morris
realizes why when he gets a shock from
the collar after he becomes overly
excited the father and son share a sad
hug as Morris realizes his collar is
actually a cruel restriction not a
privilege we're certainly relieved that
they got rid of the collars instead they
used more subtle ways to show
discrimination against predators The
Incredibles alternate opening the
opening scene of a movie is essential to
get right so it's not surprising that
multiple versions are created and that
some fall by the wayside that's exactly
what happened to this rather gruesome
opening scene from The Incredibles
it shows Bob and Helen attending a
neighborhood barbecue they're trying to
fit in with Bob helping to chop up
steaks but Helen gets into an argument
about the value of motherhood versus
professional life and distracts him and
Bob chops off his own fingers or so the
other barbecue goers believe his fingers
are actually fine and it's the first
time we realized that they aren't normal
people bob has to play along he squirts
tomato sauce on his hand to make it look
more realistic and he and Helen make a
hasty getaway they discuss how they'll
have to go through the facade of a
couple of months of bandages as the
Creator explained it shows the other
side of being a superhero which is the
burden of trying to hide such a big
secret he loved the idea of a superhero
defending being a mom so he thought it
was a shame that they didn't end up with
a moment like that in the movie but
we're happy to pass on the chopped
fingers
and now from an alternate opening to an
alternate ending what you going to do
you wouldn't kill your own The Lion King
alternate ending the grand finale is
also one of the most important parts of
any film once you've watched a movie
it's hard to imagine it finishing any
other way
well-prepared to see just how different
the ending of The Lion King could have
been what if Simba hadn't tossed scar
over the edge of Pride Rock what is it
I'd been sin by himself who was thrown
down the thaad of the bad guy winning is
almost impossible to believe and
actually in this alternate ending scar
is still defeated but not thanks to
Simba kicking him over the cliffs edge
in this deleted scene scar begs for
mercy when Simba corners him at the top
of Pride Rock and Simba spares his life
that's the same idea as the actual
ending but the crucial difference is
that in this alternate ending scar throw
Simba over the edge we fear the worst
and scar is so busy celebrating his
victory that he doesn't notice the
flames creeping up behind they engulf
him and cause his blazing end
fortunately this isn't totally dark as
Simba survives the fall
he then Nestle's up to an injured
lioness of course in the actual ending
scar meets his end by being attacked by
a hyenas either way it's pretty gruesome
cars vehicle graveyard if you're a car
the last thing you want to do is end up
in a spooky forest full of other
vehicles that are no longer alive in the
scene called lost he stumbles upon a
graveyard of old cars while trying to
make his way back to the interstate the
rusting vehicles that have trees growing
through them terrify him and it haste to
get out of there he gets tangled up and
barbed wire and that wire has a scary
old vehicle attached to it he pushes
forward faster and faster until he
breaks free his fear and panic are
palpable here's an interesting little
bit of trivia for you the scene didn't
go to waste as the idea of a car
graveyard was later used in the fourth
episode of the tales from Radiator
Springs series the cars toons episode
features the spooky forest full of old
vehicles Pinocchio Gepetto and the
goldfish animal sidekicks and pets are
there to help their human friends and
Disney movies there's certainly not
there
be eaten by them but that almost
happened to Cleo the goldfish in
Pinocchio we see it played out in a
deleted scene from the movie called
sequence 10.1 the scene was known as
starving in the belly of the whale
stored in the Disney Animation research
library this deleted scene shows the
wilder side of Walt and his story team's
imagination Geppetto is so hungry when
he's inside the whales belly that he
starts having crazy ideas he
hallucinates about strings of sausages
in the cupboard and fish cooking in the
pan Figaro the cat lips the cookbook
open to a page showing 101 ways to cook
a fish the cats inspired by this causing
him to dangle a fishing hook into the
fish bowl Gepetto's initial reaction is
to scold Figaro calling him a scoundrel
for having such thoughts but then
Geppetto gets on board with the idea and
starts imagining cooking Cleo - you
think you know someone and then BAM they
contemplate eating their pet fish
thankfully he comes to his senses and
begs Cleo for forgiveness what a relief
all around lilo and Stitch pudges fate
there are certain characters that don't
play a very big role in Disney movies
like Pudge the fish in lilo and stitch
fish but when you watch a deleted scene
about them it can change the way you
think about another character forever in
this deleted scene lilo introduces
stitch to her other best friend she
holds the fish up for stitch to kiss but
disgusted stitch pushes Pudge away poor
Pudge is left flapping on the ground and
seagull swooped in to attack lilo
desperately calls for stitch to help but
stitch just sits there laughing pretty
cruel right after the sad event takes
place lilo is furious with stitch for
allowing it to happen
she takes Pudge and lays him to rest by
her parents stitch finally realizes the
gravity of the situation and looks for
more school lilo shows forgiveness so it
further comments her character as
likable but the damage is done for
stitch if this scene had been included
in the movie it would have seriously
affected how the audience viewed Stitch
Mulan can use disruption jinyu is one of
the most terrified
villains in all the Disney Princess
movies so we definitely don't need to
see anymore examples of his brutality
that's why we're seriously relieved that
this particular deleted scene didn't
make the cut in the final mulan movie in
it we see the Hun army destroying a
village as everything goes up in flames
one of the soldiers rescues a bird from
a cage
the Falcon witnesses this happening and
then shan-yu comes out of his tent he
asks his men if they've left anything
alive and then he takes the bird out
from where the soldiers hiding it Chen
Yu throws the bird into the air where
the Falcon swoops in to destroy it and
then Chan who destroys the soldier -
it's really very disturbing the director
Tony Bancroft explained his thought
process behind the scene when developing
Shenmue they had the idea of him being a
spiritual character that can see through
the Falcons eyes they ended up cutting
the scene because they needed more time
to focus on developing the character of
Mulan instead but the director misses
some of the cool ideas they came up with
in this scene sure the mystical Falcon
link is interesting but the rest of it
definitely not cool Emperor's New Groove
patches village the Emperor's New Groove
is full of laugh-out-loud moments when
you think of it you think of a
light-hearted slapstick buddy movie you
don't think of it as a dark terrifying
film and that's because a certain
harrowing scene was deleted it shows
pochet witnessing a practice run of the
destruction of his village in the scene
Pacha leaves Emperor Kuzco palace
feeling dejected after hearing that his
village will be demolished but seeing it
is even worse than hearing it he
stumbles upon a wooden recreation of the
village and then soldiers come tearing
in and rip burn and shop up the houses
it's a bleak scene that doesn't sit
right with the rest of the movie and
that's exactly why we never got to see
it in the final cut the director
explained that emotionally it just
didn't fit the tone of the picture we
completely agree frozen-evil Elsa it's
fair to say that frozen fans are rooting
for both Elsa and Anna to have a happy
ending
but that would have been quite different
if else's character had been Evil Disney
creators first envisioned Elsa as a
straightforward villain but they decided
that it would be way more interesting if
she were a more complex character if
you're finding it difficult
imagine Elsa as the baddie just take a
look at this deleted scene
it shows the ice queen using her powers
to hurt two soldiers to drifts to snow
lifts the terrified soldiers from their
horses and raise them into the air Elsa
is controlling the icy blast and sets
about questioning them they explained
the Admiral had sent them to search for
Anna she squeezes the coils of ice as
she presses the soldiers further it's
clear from their groans that she's doing
some serious damage when they explained
al said that the Admiral is busy
building an army she comments on the
coincidence and then out comes her own
army of snowmen soldiers and they're
nothing like friendly Olaf Elsa ends the
scene with the cutting line never
underestimate the power of snow and ice
and now to finish up our look at
Disney's saddest deleted scenes we're
moving on from one evil character to the
next prepared to be shocked silence Toy
Story dad woody did you know that woody
was originally going to be a bad guy in
Toy Story we're glad they had a change
of heart about that if you're struggling
to imagine a bad woody then take a look
at this deleted scene it was before they
reinvasion his character as a good guy
the scene takes place right before they
go to Pizza Planet the other toys are
placing bets as to whom Andi will take
buzz or woody buzz is being a good sport
putting his hand out to shake Woody's
butt bad woody uses the opportunity to
wit buzz out the window seriously of
course when this happens in the final
movie it's a genuine accident but in
this earlier version it's deliberate the
other toys watch on in shock woody tries
to cover it up pretending buzz slips
what he goes on to be rude to all the
other toys he shuts the soldiers away an
order slinky to remove the rest of the
toys from the bed slinky refuses and the
entire gang dance together to throw
woody out the window Woody's voice actor
Tom Hanks was not a fan of the original
bad woody and Disney executives agreed
he almost canceled the movie after
seeing the first half fortunately the
script got reworked and woody became a
good guy we're certainly relieved about
that so that's a wrap on all 10 of the
saddest deleted Disney scenes which do
you think is the most upsetting and
do you wish had actually stayed in the
final cut be sure to let us know in the
comments below thank you for watching
make sure to subscribe to the things for
more videos like this one we'll see you
next time
[Music]